be it a frontier or a gateway to Europe
the antig is a region of vast importance
not only to the 4 million people living
there but also to the European Union and
to the rest of the world the region has
a significant impact on our oceans
ecosystems and biodiversity and has huge
potential for research development and
for international cooperation that is
why the European Union is stepping up
its existing action and engagement we
will increase our investment in
sustainable development we will work to
reduce the dramatic impact of climate
change on the region we will continue to
work together with the states and
peoples of the Arctic and with our
global partners
no individual country can tackle these
challenges on its own we must join
together as the European Union our
member states and the international
community to the benefit of the Arctic
region its inhabitants and our planet
the European Union is proud and is ready
to play its part